you're this kid and you decide to become
an actor you were a ballet dancer you
know you were one of those kids who just
was really into it you knew at an early
age what you wanted to do you're eight
years old and you're acting and dancing
and stuff
and you go out and audition for stuff
and the first audition you go on you get
it
and then the whole family picks up and
moves to new york
ostensibly i think to basically you're
the you're the great hope
of the family to make a living that's
working your brother
my older brother toby was an actor is an
actor continues to be
right so i think when we moved my father
wanted to start uh he was a truck driver
my father's a teamster and he wanted to
start a business in new york
right and so we came and obviously there
were
hopes that we might find success the
children but i will say that
because there were so many of us we
weren't the center of the family like we
would just take subways to auditions
you think you got enough attention do
you think that's why you became an actor
that you that was your way of getting
attention when you're in a family of
eight
no i think it's the opposite i think um
it's a way of having something that's
yours in a family of six or seven or
eight
right you have finally something that's
just your own
and you become somebody else which is
it's thrilling it's like it's like an
alternate universe and so then you come
home
and you you're happier to be there in a
way i mean i loved
working not because i felt i had to take
care of people but because i
loved the experience and i could
contribute to the family it was it was
an amazing family
you don't pay you don't pay attention to
school at that age right because you're
acting already you're making a living
yeah i mean i was trying to and my
mother is an educator
so it was kind of odd but we yeah i mean
i i stayed in school when schools were
you know were you the coolest like one
of the coolest kids at school
no no i was the opposite but you were on
broadway at 11 years old or something
doing annie
but nobody when you get to high school
when you leave annie and you're 14 or
almost 15 in my case
and you enter ninth grade no one no
one's interested in annie i mean
they're just they're desperate to be
anything but a small girl like you're
oh my god i would be like oh there's
that there's that girl who was in
america no i was incredibly unpopular i
had it i became very friendly with um
my best friend molly renfro um and
but we weren't invited to any parties
and we were alone
every weekend and we were really
classic outcasts i mean i was not
at all popular and it was hard to
integrate
i can't believe this i would think that
would have been my ticket to somebody
paying attention to me and being a
little bit popular i mean i had no
friends
so you're 11 you get cast in the
innocence which was on broadway
was that the one where you went for like
one audition and you just nail it
that um that was a little match girl
when i did when i was eight and then i
auditioned for the innocence and i
and i got that and my brother toby ended
up getting that as well do you think
you're a natural in the sense that
were you taking acting lessons at all or
you just went you just went in
audition and they put you on broadway
sort of i mean yeah
wow so are you like a savant or
something
no i don't think so i think i just
i i loved it were you nervous when you
would audition
when you're young you're not nervous
about anything you know it's only when
you get older and
the stakes change you know you have to
pay rent on your con ed bill and then
all of a sudden you're nervous because
you have responsibilities you know but
when i was auditioning as a kid i
loved it i mean i'm out of school if i
get this job
i'm being paid i have to imagine what
it's like to live in the turn
of the century in london and you know my
mother is dead and i have to sell these
match
i mean you know if it's something that
you're
curious about which is i guess fantasy
right but that's amazing to go on i mean
i remember the first time i was on radio
i was already
older and i was shaking that's why you
were because
you i was too old you were you were
grown up and you understood the stakes
you understood
that there were consequences to success
or not having success
you there was a whole laundry list of
things that you
were expecting from the experience when
you audition for your first role and you
get it
subsequent roles and you go out and
audition and you don't get it
was the rejection even harder for you we
like wait i'm supposed to get this
no and you never suffered from rejection
you know i mean i would i would
occasionally say like i would audition
for commercials you know two and three
times a day i would be up and down third
avenue where all those advertising
agents used to be
and i would finally i would just tell
the guys i'd be like you're not i never
get these jobs i don't know why
i'm you don't get commercials i don't
get commercials i didn't look like an
american
but that's the problem as a little girl
and you're going out on these commercial
auditions you're probably seeing
yourself oh i don't have the right look
i should do this to my face i should do
this to my body
no you didn't get discouraged no i
always felt i was
doing something i loved i mean to be to
have freedom in new york city and walk
around and
put a dime in a pay phone and see if you
have another audition and
try to catch a subway or a bus crosstalk
it was all fun
it was fun but it was also i mean it's
why
kids like playing soccer or hockey or
ballet
this was your thing this was the thing
that i love so when you're 11 what how
old are you when he got um
um annie when i was annie i was about
almost 13.
so when you're 13 then you start making
some real bread you were the understudy
first right
i was july the orphan yeah and i was the
understudy to annie yeah and then like
almost immediately the understudy u
becomes annie well i played i played
july for a year and then i played annie
for a year so that's pretty good at
least you were used to being
on stage for that because that thing was
a mega smash and then when you become
annie
you're probably making what four grand a
week or something crazy no i was
not making four grand but at the time i
was making like
more than my father it ever that's what
i mean